there's a tendency to look down on
tablature at least by classical
guitarists they think of it as two
simple crude so in this video I like to
debunk that idea by showing you that
tablature was actually the dominant
style of the notation for plucked
instruments like the loot guitar theorbo
and more for more than 400 years
[Music]
so the next part of this video I'm going
to explain what we can learn about
performance practice the composer's
intent and much more from looking at
these historical documents when we
learned to read from historical
tablature which by the way is very easy
I have to emphasize you can do this I
promise when you learn to read it and
start looking at all this free digital
content available online like websites
like imslp.org you'll find countless
examples books and books of tablature
and in that tablature one of the things
you'll notice is there's lots and lots
of symbols on the page symbols like a
sharp sign or a little squiggle or a
comma this is how Renaissance and bro
composers notated ornaments that is to
say things like trills
importance
and much more often these composers will
tell us what their symbols mean at the
beginning of each book and what you'll
see is they ornamented a lot more than
we think they did for example let's take
a peek at this famous piece by John
Dallin called the Frog galliard
foreign
each measure that's telling us to do
some type of ornament Trail the
pogiatura or immortant so if I only
played the notes on the page I would get
something like this
and of course that sounds nice but when
you actually understand what the symbols
mean the music is much more elaborate
and freely with all sorts of beautiful
decorations on top the first chord isn't
just but it's
with the trill on the top note people at
the time write about the idea that they
thought ornamentation added Grace and
charm to their music
with another one in the second measure
and then the third measure two in the
third measure actually
another one here
another one and again another one yeah
the next thing we can learn from
historical tablature is especially in
the Baroque Period they used lots and
lots of slurs I'm not holding a baroque
Guitar by the way you can learn all
about this in the video in the
description slurs are things like
hammer-ons and pull-offs so you pluck
one note in the right hand and then you
hit in the left hand hard enough to make
a pitch that's a hammer on and if you
pluck a note in the right hand and you
pluck the string with your left hand
only that's called a pull-off Baroque
music is so full of these types of slurs
[Music]
foreign
these long swooping lines tell us to
only pluck once and then
do the rest in our left hand
so knowing this brings us closer to the
performers at the time it shows us what
they wanted musically because if they
didn't write that slur and they wanted
me to play
that sounds very heavy
but what they're telling us by putting
this big swooping line over many notes
is they want it to be more elegant
they're more Legato connected and smooth
we can see a great example of slurs
being used for a very important musical
reason in this menu or minuet by Robert
de vuse
[Music]
in the B section of this dance we see
the following in slow motion
three notes in a slur
a long Trill which is slurred trails in
the broke period are slurred on guitars
and loots not done cross-string like
some Modern players
do today which makes it rather well
let's call it a non-baroque sound then
in the third measure of the B section we
actually get five notes
in a row that are played only with the
left hand
have a pluck and then several light
graceful notes which is very important
for dance music plucking everything
destroys the dance ability it makes it
sound clumsy
whereas the slurs make it sound light
even the most famous classical
guitarists like Andre Segovia have
actually famously ignored these
historical tablishers in the sense that
they didn't know what the markings on
the page all meant or they simply chose
to ignore them and it's a byproduct of
not understanding or ignoring the
historical tablature you don't get this
danceable Baroque piece instead you get
something that sounds like this
[Music]
foreign
now while I'm not of course saying this
sounds bad because sukovia was a great
musician an artist it's clear that if he
was to pay more attention to the
historical tablature and the notation he
would arrived at something completely
different
[Music]
foreign
now in case this is sounding
overwhelming wow how are we supposed to
know what all these symbols mean well
let me help you out in the same
manuscript where you'd find that minuet
by visay at the very beginning in French
he describes how to play all the symbols
he writes so he writes when I write this
little comma on this note I want you to
play
a trail a trump limo when I write this
note with a little X I want you to play
martellimo which is like a mordant if I
write a DOT below a note I want you to
play it with the index finger of your
right hand that's one dot two dots is
your middle finger so it's giving us all
sorts of information about right and
left hand fingerings ornamentation
symbols it's all there in the
manuscripts speaking of the dots under
notes for the right hand fingering this
is one of the most important things to
know about historical tablature in the
Renaissance if you look at almost any
Renaissance Loop book of which there are
many you'll see that very often under
every other note there'll be a DOT
meaning to pluck with the index finger
of the right hand so when you have long
scales like at the end of La Creme or
flow my Tears by John dowland
thank you
a DOT under each note means to play with
index and usually you play the other
note with the thumb that means we have
this alternation between the thumb and
the Index P and I in classical guitar
terminology
and because the thumb is a big heavy
digit which goes down with gravity and
the index is a weaker digit which Goes
Up Against Gravity we get strong weak
strong weak strong weak and the
Renaissance they call these good and bad
notes this is musicians beyond the grave
from 400 years ago telling us what they
considered good taste they thought it
was bad taste to play
to play Everything strong they thought
it was a good taste to play strongly
strongly strong week so bad taste would
be
foreign
and good taste with the fingers
prescribed in the manuscript
[Music]
regardless of whether or not you'd
actually like to play on period
instruments you can play directly from
the source from the manuscript and you
can learn so much about performance
practice and the composer's intent from
doing so not only that these manuscripts
are beautiful to look at and there's
more music out there just from 1400 to
1600 then you can play in a lifetime
I'll put some links in the description
to some big books of manuscripts that
you can all play through and even you
guitarists who are playing classical
steel string electric guitar you can
play directly from these manuscripts too
take your guitar which of course is
tuned
e-a-d-g-b-e and the third string G is
going to drop down to F sharp you can do
this by playing the open B string and
then the fifth fret on the third string
and then make them sound the same
[Music]
there now it's Ultra tuning you can play
directly from the manuscripts like loot
[Music]
thank you
foreign
so I really hope this video helped you
understand historical tablature and
convinced some of you guitarists to
start taking a look at it and even learn
to play from it if you enjoyed today's
video make sure you subscribe and hit
the Bell so you don't miss other videos
I post like this one if you want to help
me make more videos like this you can go
to my patreon and there you'll find lots
of behind the scenes content about what
I'm up to the videos I'm making
performances I'm giving and you'll
receive rewards like early viewing on
all my videos my CDs and you can even
get a private lesson with me and lastly
if you're interested in learning
classical guitar especially at your own
pace at home I have a beginner online
classical guitar course called classical
guitar Pro it's six hours long 53 videos
so I hope you'll check that out until
next time thanks for watching
foreign